thank you
[Music]
guys ever met somebody that you really
legitimately thought looked just like
you yeah really yeah don't say Jackson
Wang full language
I haven't met I haven't met anybody but
I've been sent the same picture of this
person like all the Google ads is it
that [ __ ] uh
I've been sent out by family members but
my own dad sent it to me he was like is
this you I'm like [ __ ] you know what I
look like that's not me obviously and
then just I've been sent that [ __ ] so
much so many times man
yeah people send it to me too they were
like is this your boy yeah I've been
said that [ __ ] like I can't even tell
you how many times it's it's pretty
funny because you guys got the same
classes and [ __ ] I'm probably not gonna
find it but who was the person that you
bumped into or you met dude who went to
UCLA his name is Sean and the people
would constantly send me photos and then
we finally met at like a club one time
and it was honestly it was one of those
things you know when somebody's like oh
here's a doppelganger you're like uh
whatever it doesn't look like me I'm
around look at this phone we're like
whoa
same height very similar height yeah and
this one like when I was younger so I
also didn't have a goatees so he didn't
like just straight up face to face or
something was he Korean
I don't remember I think it was Korean
and then also when I was younger two
people said I looked like John Cho but
that was a little bit farther away
I never met anyone that looked like me
yeah I bet dude what I [ __ ] bet oh
I've met someone that looked just like
Nick remember I sent you the picture at
the guy that came into the shop
a long time ago yeah I'll say this look
the guy kind of looked like me but he
also didn't like bro he looked like Nick
you know Nick kind of like Dopey from
Snow White that's your boy dog I'm gonna
show you who I look like I'm gonna pull
it up but yeah I look like that gray
robot dude great robot by the way
there's a point to me asking this I'll
tell you as soon as we uh no it's gonna
take a little bit so let's go ahead and
start talking all right what is it I
never met anyone that looked like Joe
either there's a bunch of people that
send me photos and I'm like yeah that's
more like I always reposted too I don't
think any of them look like you it's
just it looks like something you would
do oh like that one guy that was dancing
in Hawaii doing a tick tock yeah yeah
like it's just a guy doing something
crazy to be fair though when I first saw
I also thought it was Joe for a second
that was me too years ago when I had a
fatter belly
there's like an aura yeah it's an aura
yeah it's not really Jorah
so the reason behind me asking is
because there's a new scientific study
where they analyze doppelgangers and
they got together people who really
resembled each other the way they found
them is this really popular book uh
Photography book where this guy uh made
like a giant book of people that look
like it's just random people right so
then scientists used that they found the
people who did look the most like each
other and they wanted to see is there
any similarity between their actual
private lives that goes beyond they just
look alike and they found a lot of
things at uh correlate as far as like
some people who look like each other
having never met total different places
where they lived ended up with some of
the same habits some of the same
behaviors some of the same uh like some
some of them were smokers like some of
them just did a lot of the same [ __ ]
Tendencies everything
but you know it's like sometimes you can
see a person and you just you just kind
of know like oh this person's a [ __ ]
meth head
especially because
I'm tired yeah it's like
like you drink a lot of alcohol this
person is the Tyrant of a make-believe
land in his head because there could
only be so much human variation right
sure yeah but the thing was Not only was
that LinkedIn in this like observable
way
do you think this looks like me oh
nothing yeah dude hell yeah that looks
like you
my buddy Patrick
he says I look like this Dude Looks Like
A low-res version of you like before the
graphic skin
that's a dummy Nick dude
because the reason why I was pointing
that out is because like
um so there's a lot of traits where
biology could change the way you look
like if you see someone who's never
worked out and then when they start
working out their jaw even changes like
just from building more [ __ ] muscle
like if you've seen a before and after
of a person like it's like everything
looks different their face too well yeah
what's that homie that does barbell
stuff and he's like hella good looking
and his Jaws a [ __ ] oh Larry girl
Larry God like when you look at his
before and after that dude it's Jaws
[ __ ] he looks like the Asian Chad you
know what I mean yeah he looks like Giga
Chad yeah
so uh so he didn't have a jaw before
what do you have I mean he was like fat
kid he looked like someone that lived at
Kumon or something
no he looks like Superman dude yeah he's
not a Superman he does he does so uh
what they were able to find was that the
significance behind this is that they
were able to tell that certain people
after testing their blood actually held
some of the same genetic information oh
even though they're just [ __ ] worlds
away and they just look alike somewhere
down the line there was like the same
similar genome so maybe like the
genetics also like dictated the type of
decisions they made in their lives too
yeah which which gave them a slight clue
that maybe in some capacity DNA
governs a little bit about what we're
prone to do oh for sure so our look is
reflected also in our DNA yeah that it
could be that it could be like certain
traits that you know but it's all of
course a mixed bag no he's saying looks
is for sure associated with DNA but
maybe some DNA might be associated with
some of our like habits and or behaviors
yeah so like when you do like the
ancestry [ __ ] they tell you like oh
based on your DNA sequences and your
genome whatever they could say like oh
you're more prone to be a morning person
more prone to be a night person they
have all these different attributes that
you can look up what this Bart the Lego
one
no way especially the Legos
but when he smiles his eyes have to
disappear like me like let me smile eyes
disappear
that's interesting yeah Isn't that cool
like so what were the are there any
examples of like these two malafakas do
the same [ __ ] yeah I feel like it would
have to be really unique habits for me
to be like more impressed in a sense
yeah it's like a lot both of them smoke
it's like well a lot of smokers yeah you
know what I mean
but if it's like Bart's doppelganger
also it was like a gym rat you know what
I mean and just [ __ ] owned his own
gym and it was like entrepreneurial I'd
be like wait a minute or if he cleaned
his butthole the way I cleaned my
butthole yeah full like half finger yeah
I mean very unique like submarine
[ __ ] telescope thing
I found Nick
you know this guy that's the dude from
Kunk Russell holy [ __ ] you are so
Chinese I know that [ __ ] Bro all it has
to do is like I'll fight that guy
that's such a good movie it's one of the
best dude so good yeah I remember a long
time ago there was a dude when um when I
was in choir in high school we would do
these yearly choir festivals where we
would get together with 12 other schools
of the same conference from all over
Cali and we would do this like mega
concert with everybody oh [ __ ] during
the like a rear of the world kind of
yeah exactly like that so during the
rehearsals they would split off all guys
and all girls so imagine this like mega
church where there's like hundreds of
dudes just like on the stands and we're
all learning a song and I remember
directly across me there was this guy
that I thought looked exactly [ __ ]
like me and I and I caught eyes with him
and I could tell he was thinking the
same [ __ ] and we started Mad Dogging
each other like because like I was 15 at
the time so I didn't like that I thought
you guys want to team up and sing the
same notes no so we we really didn't
like each other for no [ __ ] reason
like two days straight we just were
staring at each other during while
singing Jesus songs
and then and like come to come to uh
find out later on I meet a girl there
that's like friends with him and I'm
like yo I don't like that dude I got a
problem with it because I was a [ __ ]
idiot at the time and she's like I think
you could really get along with it I'm
like not [ __ ] that Fulton and then like
for some stupid reason we um I knew
where he was gonna be that night so uh
on the campus that we were all staying I
went over there and I don't know why I
had a [ __ ] knife with me so like I
thought [ __ ] was gonna go down you never
know and then like literally we just
like dog at each other like we were just
in this dark hallway just on the
opposite side of the hallway and our
mutual friends in between and we're both
just like
we don't say no words right yeah on the
last day we decide to [ __ ] say hi to
each other like inside the church and
he's the [ __ ] coolest dude and we
have the same [ __ ] mannerisms and
everything and he goes bro that night in
the hallway I had a knife too
twins me each other with the same
mentality but he lived all the way in
[ __ ] like Newbury Park or some [ __ ]
and I was in San Gabriel so I'm like bro
we're not gonna see each other no more
he goes you know what take my flannel
bro and he gave me his like he had a
dope ass blue flannel what did you give
him nothing I think I gave him like a
windbreaker or some [ __ ] he's like All
My Friends Are Dead too man
oh my God
I wonder if he still looks like you you
know like for years he he really did
look a lot like me yeah and but then
sadly I think he got into gangs and some
[ __ ] and just went full on like he just
disappeared but he's the cool guy in The
Gangs though he's like we traded like so
you know back in the time back in the
day it wasn't gay to take Studio photos
with your homies when I took which
should be reconsidered am I right guys
like we [ __ ] traded
is Newbury Park like gangster thug ass
hobbies and he's wearing his blue
fladdle and then when he gave it to me I
took it in the same shirt if you guys
kissed that would have been less gay bro
his name was arvind or with a d at the
end that's why he joined the gang yeah
he was just like one of those dudes so
wherever you at bro
you're alive dog yeah that's cool My
Doppelganger bro I wonder
[Music]
foreign
[Music]